MALE SPEAKER: Lists are a
special type of object that
hold other objects.
I can initialize
lists by simply
using the List function.
I can create items in the list
by providing arguments to the
List function.
What is important to understand
is that a list can
hold objects of all
different types.
In this example, the first
object is a numerical vector
of length five.
The second object is a character
vector of length
one, and the third object is a
Boolean vector of length one.
If I wanted to access an
item, I use the sub
segment Double Bracket.
I can also add on new items,
even providing the character
name for the item.
When a list has named objects,
those objects can be accessed
using a special dollar sign
notation that is reminiscent
of the same notation
for data frames.
Lists also aren't restrained
to holding just vectors.
They can also hold matrices,
data frames,
and even other lists.
Lists are so powerful, since
they create helpful ways to
organize diverse sets
of data or results.
Often times I have many groups
of data, and it would be
helpful to calculate statistics
for each.
I might organize these
statistics using a list.
I'm going to load in the stock
data, just as we have in the
last couple of videos.
My goal will be to create
a summary of the
prices for each stock.
I'm going to do this
using a For Loop.
The first line in the
For Loop will
identify the rows of interest.
The second line will calculate
the summary and start an
object called Stock Summary.
I also shouldn't forget to
initialize the Stock Summary
object here as a list.
Finally, I can take a
look at the results.
Not surprisingly, there's
a lot to look at.
If I wanted, I could look at
a specific summary for a
particular stock, say,
Google's stock.
What I've done here in
just six lines of
code is very powerful.
I've calculated summaries for
every stock in the data set,
and this code works regardless
of I have five stocks, or five
thousand stocks.
In other instances I might
choose to do something even
more complex, like fit a linear
model to the data for
each stock separately.
Even in that complex case,
a list can be used
to store the result.
I noted in the last video that
as you become more familiar
with R, you'll find out that
there are more helpful
functions do operations commonly
done in For Loops.
This also true with this
example, which could have been
written much more
compactly using
some additional functions.
Some of these functions we'll
encounter in the next section,
like the functions
By and Apply.
Great work on making
it through the
second section of videos.
Take a short coffee break,
practice what you've seen, and
then get started on
the third section.